the morning after a politically stormy
night
it took 50 mps to vote against and seal
the fate of the pro-serbian and
pro-russian ruling coalition led by
drita nabazovic discontent over the
signing of a long disputed accord with a
powerful serbian orthodox church the spc
as well as stagnation over the country's
path towards integration with the
european union led the majority in
parliament to withdraw their support for
obazovich's leadership obazovic came to
office in april and has presided over
the shortest period in power in the
country's political history marking a
new era of instability he had attempted
to fend off the vote of no confidence by
offering a cabinet reshuffle
to no avail
i'm happy and i congratulate the new
coalition of takanovich and becket
i hope that they will quickly form a
government we are ready to step down
it was the signing of the accord with
the spc that sealed abbasovich's
political fate it reignited tensions and
was fiercely criticized by the president
milo jukanovic
a third of montenegro's population
identify as serbs and the largest
religious group serbian orthodoxy
while the country broke away from serbia
in 2006 the spc never fully recognized
its independence
critics of the accord including the
president say the church is harboring
the interests of serbia rather than
montenegro
serbia rules the axis of the sea and
russia wants also next to the adriatic
so i think that they are trying to use
this destabilize montenegro in order to
make weaker also
nato alliance and montenegro is the
weakest element of the of the of the
nato
president giulkanovich's most urgent
task is to appoint a new prime minister
who will have 30 days to form a cabinet
even then it may prove too weak to forge
your way out of the crisis with many
calling for early elections to resolve
this political dilemma sony gallego al
jazeera